okay well i'm luis alvarez and a
responsible for bt global services for
Europe Middle East Africa and Latin
America it's clear that the health of
employment is one of the challenges we
really face in the in the globe my
perspective is that we need to help
young people in three main areas the
first one is facilitating that they can
access to the right skills and that they
can learn and be trained in with the
right new wave information technology or
science or just the tools that they need
to find a job the second one is allowing
them to be entrepreneurs and you and
ensure that they can build their own
businesses and help them to create the
round place in there in the globe and
the third one is also making use of the
best potential opportunities on a global
basis I think that talent now is global
is no longer a local thing so we need to
facilitate that they can move and learn
from what is happening around the clock
so skills making sure that we allow them
to create their own businesses the round
opportunities and making this global
initiatives this is a way of fight
against health unemployment